and Raven
one of the things I think screenwriters
forget is that even though so much of it
is the screenwriting is personal and
comes from the inside it is still a
craft there are things you have to know
you have to know how to format a script
you have to know how to construct a
script just so that you can get past
those gatekeepers you know the agents of
the readers or the whoever because
they're looking for reasons not to read
your script they're looking anything
that says amateur are gonna throw it
away because they don't have they don't
have the time them and you know what
we're hearing you know an agent that was
on one of the panels saying you know
that on his desk every week is you know
50 scripts to start the week every week
and you know and that's and he has to
rely on a filter system hehe can't cover
all that behind every week because you
know that then the next week begins in
here held here's that pile of scripts
again